[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hi my name is timmy and welcome to this
one-off special event
gamespot i'm the nerd council present
the men's mental health forum this event
is forming part of men's mental health
month here in the uk
november marks a time where we look at
men's mental health as a whole
and address what it means to be a man
and how negative and positive
stereotypes
can affect men's mental health
everywhere the nerd council was founded
by myself
ludon ryan and has grown from strength
to strength in becoming a global
platform
where we can offer communities to people
covering all things
nerdy in the space of anime comics
gaming film and tv
we have grown to have a community that
allows us to have both online and
offline events such as
our infamous quizlets and live podcast
shows the nerd council has dedicated
itself to offering a safe space for
people to come together
to discuss things that they love in an
environment that they can actually
thrive in as well
we saw the opportunity to discuss
something that was very important to us
we decided to team up with gamespot to
produce this event to make sure that
we're having conversations about
mental health within the game of space
there can be a lot of negativity
associated to the gaming space
especially when it comes to men's
attitudes
and mindsets to gaming as a whole their
interactions with other gamers
and their value within the industry
which is why we're so thankful to be
able to host this event for you guys
joining us for this one-off special
event will be i know tomlinson who's an
actor and a streamer
leader at the rainbow arcades ben
thompson streamer and anime lover
chocolate kieran
streamer and mental health advocate
sugar ash fundraising manager at
calm faye evelyn and studio head
administer theory
dominic matthews we hope you leave this
forum an event with a better
understanding of your own mental health
and the mental health of those around
you
while this event does address men's
mental health we do want to assure you
that we understand that mental health
affects us born
so we hope that you leave this event
with a better understanding of your own
mental health as well
please sit back and enjoy
so if we start off with um hey what's
happening everybody my name is i know
i'm an actor uh comedian and a voice
over artist as well
i've been in the games industry for for
a number of years mainly in the acting
kind of department appearing in
various video games and things uh and
i've always just always been an avid
gamer since when i was a kid
hey guys uh really nice to be here
thanks for me and thanks to me for
putting this together it's really cool
um so i work for calm which is the
campaign against living miserably
you're a suicide prevention charity um
and we
have sort of just in the last sort of
six to 12 months started a foray into
gaming i'm really crap at games so thank
you for having me here
uh ash also known as show ganesh um i
am a gaming content creator
um also freelance within the gaming
industry doing campaigns and marketing
and stuff for
i want to say about four years now
um primarily with konami but also
bunching up with other companies as well
um but yeah that's that's me um ben or
little likes tv and i've
been content creating for five years on
twitch while working a full-time job and
it's
stressful but it's fun at the same time
um outside of that
i actually work as a network support
engineer for a big isp company you would
never expect it because i'm incredibly
immature
but that's pretty much it for me
i'm don matthews uh studio head of ninja
theory
um we're a uk games developer part of
the xbox game studios group um
and we released a game called hellblade
center with sacrifice a couple years
back which
tells the story of a character who
experiences um a serious
uh mental health difficulty i'm kieran
nice to meet you guys thank you for
having me as well by the way i
appreciate it
um i'm a huge lover of anime nintendo
and jrpg games is pretty much what i do
on
both twitch and youtube that's pretty
much it from me okay um the first
question i have for you all
is how has gaming helped with your
mental health and we'll start with
i know with my mental health i i would
say it's always kind of been
something that's kind of always been
there for me ever since i was young
when i was a young real quick story i
used to move around a lot uh different
schools because
we used to move to different houses and
council houses and things like that i
had to really quickly make friends in
the playground when i was younger
because i'm just hopping to new places
meeting new people all the time and new
kids
and the best way i i found to kind of
integrate into with these new kind of
communities and schools was chatting
about video games talking about mario
and sonic in the playground and talking
about how mario's better than sonic all
day every day
of course of course it would it would
help me out because otherwise
i felt really lonely from jump from you
you get a whole bunch of
friends you make in a school then
suddenly you have to kind of uproot your
life and move to a completely different
place with completely different people
and you have to kind of start again and
as a young kid that kind of plays its
toll on you
uh gaming was always kind of my way into
kind of getting new friends but also
kind of keeping me happy
at the same time just sitting down
playing a nintendo game hey i know you
said your crap at video games
has gaming helps your mental health at
all there's a really bad game i can't
remember what it's called it's on my
phone
it's not so not to the level you guys
play but it's basically
like a piece human was good at games
yeah exactly
it's basically um a piece of cheese that
you've got to get through a maze of
mouths um so like you can't let it get
eaten
and honestly like being able to just
switch off and go and have something to
focus on um
and sort of just take a step back from
the news world event whatever is
going on like even just 50 minutes of
like focus
can make a really big difference it's a
massive effect on my mental health
um i actually did a stream of the day i
was just like kind of just doing a just
chatting stream talking to my audience i
was talking about the fact that
for me video games is very much
therapeutic for me it's
it's my escape from just the general
stresses of
life and i mean this year's been a major
for pretty much everybody oh yeah
um and just being able to have i guess
more freedom than ever to just really
kind of throw myself
into the world of gaming and just kind
of be who i want to be for that
period of time and be in that world um
it yeah it makes
makes a huge difference and obviously
being able to create content around that
as well
i can definitely resonate with that
absolutely um ben
how about your perspective yeah well
pretty much the same as an l really i
moved around
um a lot as a kid as well and um
i was always the kind of the shy one
that never really wanted to speak to
anybody and the only thing i had in
common with
other children or many of these
different schools uh was the fact that i
played video games and you know even
outside of that outside of school i
could escape because you know
being one of the very few black people
in a very
very white school there was always the
bullying so i could be somebody else at
that time when i was going through a
little bit of an identity crisis
played havoc with my mental health so
playing games i could be
that character i could fully immerse
myself and evolve you know grow within
this video game
become part of it which obviously
layered me down this path
now i'm playing games for people that
are in my situation that wish they had
someone to
be connected to or watch while they're
playing these video games they
understand what it was that i went
through back when i was a kid i've
definitely seen the impact
you and the rainbow arcade have had on
so many people so
it's to be commended um dom you
obviously work for a gaming studio so
i don't know whether your perspective is
a little bit different in terms of how
gamers help your mental health because
obviously you
you literally work and create games so
i don't know can you double a little bit
into that yeah i mean for me definitely
like as
a kid i always remember playing um evils
up there like
i remember doing my like exams like
gcses and stuff and i would
i would give myself like 45 minutes of
revision and then i could fit in one
game of pro ego and that was
how i got through my gcses and my a
levels and when i was at uni as well it
was like that that was always the way i
did it i needed that 15 minutes of
escape
last one is kieran yeah very similarly
to what
dom mentioned just said and faye earlier
actually um game is kind of helped in a
way that it's
an escape almost like dom said literally
like meditation where you're able to
kind of
focus and hone in on one thing and
distract yourself from everything else
and it's great in that way but
also it's kind of helped my mental
fortitude in a way
in regards to like challenging games to
help build up kind of have a
stronger mentality when it comes to
challenges
in real life as well faye you mentioned
um using gaming as an escape and
obviously this year has been crazy in
terms of coved and
knockdowns and personally i've had to
use gaming as a way to escape
or manage even the situation that we're
in um how has
kovid and the local situation affected
you guys mentally um
let's start with ben um it's been a mess
it's like
it's so exciting i know it sounds really
strange but it was exciting at first the
concept of working from home but
being one of the first to work from home
has kind of um
you're there for a couple of weeks and
you think this is fine everything's
working fine and then you realize you
can find to your one
area the very minimal interaction going
out and
um the things that you took for granted
like seeing your friends just casually
on the fly
i missed that so much so not to say that
when locked down
because it didn't really end in my
perspective it just was reinforced
if you know what i mean so yeah um i
think i've gotten used to it now
and i started to enjoy my own company
more and finding things to like
uh push me uh to the next level in terms
of what i'm doing on twitch now
and you know that that was just a hobby
a year ago i never expected anything was
going to
be the way that it is now but um i've
got things to look forward to and i'm
constantly look filling that time where
i'd be sitting in my own thoughts
you know um with positive things
a distraction if you will while
obviously keeping everybody safe
no i i can definitely resonate with that
i think there was a point when the
knockdown first started around
march april where i was literally
winning ready to give up on everything
but i thought
let me try and put my order my content
creation
i started streaming more i found
enjoyment in gaming and exit gaming was
a release for an escape for me from
the dread that was a lockdown um dom how
about you how's it looked i'm being for
you
yeah tough i think like i think yeah
initially it's
kind of exciting being able to maybe
achieve like a bit of a better work-life
balance but
i think um like the lack of space for
yourself like i think
i'm very conscious now that you have to
make time and space for yourself you
know that you might have gotten your
community to work or you might have got
just during the day
um so i think that's something i'm super
conscious of but also
just getting outside like i know that
sounds silly but actually no it's right
i need to get outside i need to get some
sunlight and some fresh air and actually
be outside
it's super easy i think to kind of wake
up be at work or kind of do your thing
all day long
you know play some games and then that's
it and kind of before you know it like
two three days in before you've actually
been outside
yeah or even just turn off the news yeah
i guess like what don was saying it's
been it's been tough for everyone really
and i guess in terms of how it's
affected people mentally
in terms of their health uh it's i don't
think we can even
comprehend the the amount of how it's
affected everybody uh especially uh
people
i guess people in the arts especially
i'm in the arts uh i do i'm a stand-up
comedian as well
most weekends i was out on the road in
different cities doing stand-up comedy
gigs in comedy clubs
all of that's gone and it's and it's a
case of
i know a lot of people comedians i know
and actors especially
uh it's almost like they've lost their
purpose and
what what they were what they felt they
were on this earth to do they can no
longer do it
and i guess uh for me like dom said i
had to kind of try and be proactive
about okay what can i do what are the
things i can do
i'm someone who likes to kind of try and
keep fit or the best i can and so what
i've been doing is i've been playing
ring fit adventure
on literally just trying to trying to
keep my fitness levels up
and as well as just trying to be there
for people as well just like
platforms like twitch i think a lot of
people think it's just about
watching people play games it's not it's
about uh community building it's about
the community around it and it's about
people can kind of checking in on you
seeing how you're doing and you can
check in on them and say oh yeah how's
things been going with you today and
it's and it's almost a nice way of
people to kind of like you know what
like hasn't been too great but now that
i'm here i'm like i'm enjoying the vibe
and
and my afternoon is getting better and
it's those kind of small nuggets of
things that i think
are important and i think we should
acknowledge that platforms like twitch
are providing in this current landscape
it's so great to hear you say that
because that's why
um calm and myself have been so
passionate about starting to like
get to know the community and bring
gaming into like the core
of how we speak to the world like we use
comedy we use football
we use music a lot and actually like
we've recognized that there's this
amazing
it's already a community that like takes
such good care of itself
so how do we help like support that and
and um
like become more part of it because i
think a lot of people forget it's
uh as everyone's at home people trying
to everyone's watched all their netflix
movies and seen everything
they want to kind of engage with
something new and entertaining to kind
of
experience but at the same time tv's not
really providing that it's
it's not fast enough it's not it's not
live enough it's not interactive enough
and i think platforms like youtube and
twitch and
i guess facebook gaming they're they're
kind of providing that landscape for
people
you know you know what i'm not really
into games but i like cooking and let me
try
watching this person like cook in their
kitchen and it's that nice kind of it
gives that homely kind of feel you know
where people used to say
they used to just turn on the radio just
to have something going on in their
house
like they don't want to be there
themselves and quiet it's kind of like
that in a way where you know you don't
necessarily have to kind of fully engage
with the streams you're watching but you
can have it on in the background you can
what someone's doing and then you know
maybe get on with some work check some
emails come back and they're still doing
whatever they're doing and it's nice
i mean i will say that and nell's
probably one of my favorite streamers
ever like yeah he's too good
like honestly and nell streams bring me
so much joy it's just his energy is
infectious like
he don't i don't do no evening's jesus
how do you juggle being a father in your
profession while maintaining your mental
health obviously my kids are
like top priority um but then
you also kind of have to for for their
sake and your own
make sure that you're good as well and
who are yourself and make sure that
you're in a good enough space to be able
to be positive
around them especially the way
everything is going on at the moment i
think since
lockdown has happened and i've just
spent less time
traveling and such i'm literally just
in these four walls managing pretty much
all my life within this house
i'm kind of able to deviate that up a
bit more healthily and like i say
um i'm i don't think i'm particularly
great at it at the moment
it's an ongoing process one thing that
this has taught me is that
um i guess particularly as men with the
the sorts of pressures that just come
societally
with men and providing and being strong
for everybody else
i've had to learn to be realistic with
myself um
and kind of be easy on myself also next
question as a father who's talking about
their mental health
how old you raise awareness and
understanding to your children or mental
wellbeing yeah it's a big thing for me
and obviously
becoming increasingly open about it so
when it comes to my kids
the way i would talk about that with
them or kind of
express that with them has to differ
just because of their levels of
comprehension so with my eldest son
um i'm quite frank and open about with
him like i've
spoken very candidly about the fact that
you know i suffered with depression
anxiety and
what that does how that makes me feel
like i've talked about the
the mortality of it essentially with him
i'm fortunate in that he's quite
switched on and a very good listener and
that i'm able to have that conversation
with him um still in a relatively
child-friendly way but also
quite honest um whereas like with my
younger two um i still don't hide away
from it with them like they will see me
depressed and you know struggling they
see me at
rock bottom but the main thing i talk to
them about is to say
you know sometimes dad's not feeling 100
sometimes i struggle sometimes i need to
cry sometimes i need sometimes i need a
hug
and i'm very affectionate with them in
that sense i wanted to ask you guys
at what stage in your life did you
realize that you could use gaming
as a form of excavation because for me
personally i play i've always played
games from young but for me
i didn't realize i could use it like
that and so until i was my teenage years
i got to a point where i could put like
my headset on
and then i'd be in like my own little
bubble that was like my world
so i kind of show you guys so um ben
do you want to start off um i think it
was like when i left
high school if i'm truly honest um you
know you're like friends forever i'll
see you
around and you do a lot of stuff well i
didn't go to college because me in
education just don't get on
but um after you know one when
everything dies down you're thinking
okay i've
spent so much time getting to know
certain people for so long and now the
safest people known to me have
disappeared
that's when i was already like deep into
final fantasy 11 my first sort of
mmrpg and i spent like 10 years
uh playing that game with people all
over the world i was always i've always
been like really socially anxious anyway
but going out and meeting new people was
quite difficult in in this in a sense
with that
with that in mind playing final fantasy
again i spence i'm still friends with a
lot of them now
and yeah since high school it's pretty
it's been crazy
really crazy and it just sort of evolved
from there obviously moving cities was
the another big thing that happened
again i'm moving into a place where i
don't know very many people
and expecting to have this lifestyle um
of
getting to absolutely everybody which i
did my best with that but i would always
fall back and feel safe
in an online game where i knew you know
there's always going to be the people
that i've known for years there
and it was that was a safe place for me
it's a lot of massive stress relief i'll
tell you that much
because manchester really can throw it
to you sometimes
honestly
um kieran same question to you man like
when did you notice gaming was an escape
for you
i i feel like i've always been doing it
subconsciously
like from a really really young age like
i remember my first um
my first playstation game was digimon
world and i just remember being on that
and just sulking into it and just kind
of
just being in there away from everything
but i think when i became more conscious
of it was
probably when i started to play halo 3
on xbox 360 with friends
around the time i was kind of doing
exams in gcse around that time like i
i do remember being like super worried
and anxious about how well i do in
school
and just kind of playing with my friends
and just kind of forgetting about that
online it was just like
i don't know just forget everything it
was like just back in
the game world with my friends and not
worrying about anything going on
in you know like uh real world worries
and yeah
it's quite similar to my experience
because i think i was at that same point
sort of near exams
and i was playing in skyrim and i was
just like
i was just i dropped so many hours into
skyrim non-stop and it was sort of just
a way to like
zone out and take a step away from
everything so yeah i get it
um what about you ash yeah so
consciously probably since my teens
um again you know the soaking hours into
master league
when i became acutely aware of it
probably my mid-twenties
yeah just knowing that i was gonna set
some time away
just to chill um
the same way that people would do with
tv and
some people will say okay end of the day
i'm gonna wind down bottle of wine
and watch soaps or whatever like that
never appealed to me but then
i realized i could equate that with
video games and that's when it became
a part of my daily routine i will play
video games every single day
as a mental health exercise take it back
to ben real quick um ben
obviously you founded the rainbow arcade
what do you thought the barriers of
entry
into the gaming space for lgbtq people
and how they impact mental health
it's the barriers mentally into is
difficult within video games because
it's always
we always look at it from an alpha male
perspective there's always you can't you
can't game with us because
you know being any form of lgbtq
you're underminded you are always going
to be like this player oh no i'm going
to raise my hands up the keyboard this
is not how you play the game
you know i'll just do a trash basically
you've always beaten
let's just say for lack of a better word
uh when it comes to
uh get well being gay in that community
or in any gaming community um but this
is the thing
how it's evolved from that we sort of
had to say well if you don't want us in
your space we're gonna create our own
little part within it
and then the part just overflows because
it's drawing people in
and people feel safer with those and
then everybody else on the outside the
ones that didn't want us in the first
place so like well actually what are you
doing actually because everything looks
quite fun over there now
and then they learn they learn from us
from the understanding watching those
that we are just the same as everybody
else it's just
we have we happen to be lgbtqia plus
it's never going to get any easier let's
put it that way oh definitely um
it's really it's not going to get any
easier but the thing is it's slowly but
surely
our presence uh and remember arcade just
very reminders
john john and justin mainly that uh
raised the rainbow okay
but it's um that it's you know we are a
safe place and not only
it's not all about games all the time we
talk about everything that's going on
within the lgbtq
plus community and their mental health
and again we want this to be a safe
positive environment you'll never see
one tweet out of place you'll look like
as in
we everything is consciously thought
through we want to protect the community
we're not there to you know put somebody
in a pedestal it's about
sales and marketing it's not that
everybody is welcome i mean ben
obviously because you're a community
leader has anyone in the rainbow arcade
ever come to you
wanting to discuss with their own mental
health and how have you kind of managed
that
see this is what we're quite proud of
for throwing blockade um
we talk openly and honestly amongst each
other
so we have our own discord as a team
where um we talk about absolutely
everything that's going on obviously in
the outside world
but then we have a personal section
that's just for us and
what i'm very proud of in every single
member is that we talk openly into each
other and we talk from personal
experiences if we
reply or we talk to each other about it
it's always from person to experience or
not you should do this
we'll give them the opportunity and send
them in the right direction not just
part them off and say i don't know how
to deal with that sorry acknowledging
that
and giving them the tools that they need
again um i think the
community is a collective does that
which is which is wonderful
but what do you guys change in the last
few years for men to open up more or ask
ask
what done before you go i would say for
me what i've noticed in the last few
years for
mental health i would say is men again
educate a bit more as well and people
being more open as well and they've seen
things
like the social media through the
internet through things in real life and
just seeing that how to deal with
something
that's affecting me but i don't know the
reason why for example me it's just very
present
moments in my time where i've things
have affected me for so long but i
didn't know why before i gotta get to
the borders and find out and you get
diagnosed you find out what's happening
and how to go away and do all that and
also
speaking to people you find that they're
going through things like yours as well
just
being open about it so um what would you
say yeah
i think you're right like i think i
think the big change is um
like i want us to get to a place as a as
a society and as a culture where
uh i'm talking about mental um health
challenges and difficulties is the same
as talking about physical health
challenges you know yeah
but i think the big thing is a is a
maybe it's generational but it's a
culture change of being able to
people to have the confidence to say i'm
struggling today i'm not feeling great
and then other people going well that's
cool like do you need to help you
want to talk about it you want to chat
about it and moving as far away as we
can from this concept of
men having to to man up right yeah
like that friends yeah i hate such a
look at supreme yeah
yeah and the idea of being strong having
to be a strong man and having to be
you know because i like i know from my
own experiences when i've struggled
um i i haven't wanted to talk about it
at times and this was kind of many years
ago because
i don't want to scare people around me
all right i'm the i'm the i'm
on the mail here like i don't want
people to be worried about me
like i'm all fine i'm all good don't
worry and i think more people talk about
it and say
it's not a weakness no not at all you're
struggling
it is not it's not a weakness everyone
is on this same journey as a human being
and you can have ups and you're going to
have downs i i've had
problems with ocd and and struggled with
uh struggled with that and
um i remember talking to someone about
it saying like oh i i i would have to do
these things i'd have to
say these things or do these little
rituals and that would make me feel at
ease and comfortable
in the world and and someone said to me
oh really like i always saw you as like
a really level-headed guy and i was like
and i don't have the path that we need
to go right now
it's not it's not about being level
headed it's about
being a human and experience well
why is it you know and that's and it's
and it's fragile
and we can't cope with that like our
brains can't cope with the fact that the
world is fragile and
and nothing is determined and we have to
find our part through it and just just
one
one other quick point about like um like
people within communities like reaching
out and
like knowing it's a it's a safe place to
come and talk about these things like we
really experienced that on with hello
blade and we when we shipped hellblade
um we told the story of a character who
experienced psychosis and
we created a bunch of dev diaries to
talk about how we'd done that and
it struck me so much that just from us
releasing the game
made people want to come and talk to us
and come and talk to me about their
mental health difficulties they didn't
know me
at all but i would get emails from
people saying
hey i've just played hellblade and it
made me
want to tell you about my experience and
some people said like i haven't told
anyone
else i haven't told my family and
friends i'm effectively telling a
stranger here and the only reason
they're telling
me is because they see me as a safe
place because i've talked about i've
worked on a game
that treats these subjects in in in the
right way
and that kind of made me really think
about like
wouldn't it be great if that person's
friends or family with that safe haven
they could do a far better job i
actually kind of realized that i had
like ocd or ocd type tendencies as a
result
as a result of hellblade because we
started working with a
professor in psychiatry and neuroscience
and i was sitting with him and with
other people who
themselves were telling us their stories
of experiencing psychosis
and it felt like such a privilege
because i got to sit there and listen to
these people's stories and listen to the
science
um and it made me think oh maybe those
things that i do
maybe the fact that i talk to magpies
and i do these things
maybe this is this is connected
you maybe go and actually google it like
and my
my kind of story is i i found a website
that talked about ocd
and i was like reading down going yep
yeah
yeah yeah yeah same experience
but you know what that's that's that's
really really really that was really
really reassuring to me
because you could go it's not just me
it needs to be more mainstream and like
when games and media
kind of put it out there for people to
kind of experience then they can kind of
realize
oh actually they can they can latch on
to be different things and they can kind
of identify things i guess that's why
representation as a whole is just like
important
massively yeah once people can kind of
identify and see themselves in different
situations or scenarios or even just
like small parts of a game where it's
like oh
i know what like sydney was going
through at this particular point i'm i'm
going through a similar thing and it's
that kind of connection that i think the
more that is mainstream
the more it's out there and open the
more we can kind of talk about it and it
and it's not taboo
you know what um i'll ask you because
you're on the point now why do you think
it's changed for men to open up more now
as well
no i think like what dom was saying i
think it's like a genuine
generational thing it's a cultural thing
technology has played a huge part in
terms of
people being able to kind of educate
themselves i know some people they
educate themselves in
in false things but like uh in terms of
people being able to
acquire knowledge now it's it's not a
thing of you're just spouting ignorant
stuff to someone else and then they just
have to believe it now you can ask
google say yo google what's the deal
with this and you can kind of find out
for yourself in terms of just talking
about it to
loved ones and friends i feel i feel
like people are feeling a bit more
open to kind of do those things like
i've had conversations with my
mum in the last few years that i never
probably would have had
i or i never would have saw myself
having when i was younger as
as time's gone on and i've educated
myself on things to do with
me and my mental health and my
medicinability and then i look at my
family and it's like
it's like no no no like this situation
would have happened then we would have
just like
we would have just like oh just left it
and tried to carry on as if nothing's
happened and then it's like no no
actually let's address this let's talk
about it let's open up about it
also you think what would you think has
changed to make men more open to being
open up because you're afraid you're
calm as well you know what do you see
what's been the shift for you
it's essentially a like very steady
cultural
shift towards being realistic about the
fact that statistically they say one in
four people
battles with their mental health at some
stage during their life and khan says
four in four people
have mental health everyone has mental
health if you broke your leg
you would get it fixed so if something's
going on with your mind
why wouldn't we address that and we talk
quite openly about how we feel
physically
so why wouldn't that be something that
we do about our mental health
and i do think thankfully um we are
seeing like we've said generationally
you see these changes i think the more
that um campaigns like calm and other
mental health charities that are out
there and there are so many great ones
out there
and you know we are all campaigning
towards getting rid of the stigma around
um a lot of sort of toxic masculinity
stereotypes of like you you have to be
the breadwinner you have to be the
strong one
we know that a lot of people are better
with their mental health it comes down
to like i've lost my job
and i can't support my family and i feel
a lot of shame around that and
so just getting rid of all of these
things like recognizing that and that
it's okay
like we've seen throughout this
conversation to talk
to people and if you don't necessarily
have a haven or if you're feeling
really shy to talk to your family or
friends knowing that places are calm
samaritans they are health brands out
there the dream would be for example
being able to like
get people message in game if we were
working with the
university and that kind of stuff yeah
that would be crazy yeah
wouldn't it i feel like with the uh the
stereotype of strength as well the
strongest thing a person can actually do
is
be open and honest with how they're
feeling and who they are anyway right so
yeah i feel like to say that speaking on
how you're feeling whether that be
something
negative or positive in regards to your
emotion
is it it doesn't make sense to me to
call that
a weak thing when it is you know it's
something that's hard and difficult
yeah super strong to be able to do that
there is strength and vulnerability that
that's something that's fast yeah
by my therapist like a couple years back
and it's
rung true since like there is true
strength in being vulnerable whether
that's being vulnerable
emotionally even even sometimes
physically being
sad or being happy that vulnerability is
true strength
things are getting better i feel yeah i
i mean just in
with friends that i know like 10 years
ago
telling them to go see a therapist like
that's not yeah
a few of them have been and then and the
ones that still haven't they're
they're contemplating it you can tell
like there's a shift happening and
they're not quite there yet we're not
quite there yet but
you can tell that there that that kind
of mindset that they did have
is shifting and then actually hold on
maybe if i do kind of like speak to
someone about this that
things could kind of change for the app
for me um next question
why has khan become involved in gaming
in the last six months oh well
a little bit because of everything that
i've just touched on
and and also a little bit sort of
zeitgeisty i was
looking at um fundraising through gaming
because a lot of people do stream
do charity streams which is amazing it
really is
just a really beautiful phenomenon uh
in terms of supporting charities around
the world um and then
yuki who's a games industry body got in
touch with us
and to talk about taking care of sort of
the
the industry start and how we look after
people and then
about two months later we went into
lockdown and we
sort of said the world's on pause so
let's take time to take care of
ourselves and gaming is one of the ways
to do that and again like we all keep
talking about social distancing and we
sort of said well
we have to physically distance but that
doesn't mean that we have to socially
disconnect
and games and platforms like discord and
so on and so forth are ways of
maintaining those connections also 75 of
all suicides are committed by men in the
uk
what can we do as a society to change
this the uk loses uh
125 people a week to suicide which is
just
so a week a week wow yeah
it's a huge statistic and and if you
think about the number of people that
each of those losses
impact the ripple effect of that the
fact that we don't
um sort of talk about it as much as we
should be given how many people we know
are affected by that loss and
i think sort of the main things that we
can do and certainly what calm does we
campaign
for change we campaign to get people
talking we campaign to reduce
stigma around suicide and around mental
health
um and as you say 75 of those
125 losses to suicide a week are male
and i just think everything we've
touched on
in this conversation helps contribute to
those changes
i think um being part of making it okay
to say when you're feeling crap getting
your family and friends to
like embrace it and please always feel
free to sign post
to calm i'll do a little plug the
and i'll calmzone.net man yeah plug away
and i'll help land in web chat they are
open
365 days a year 5 p.m to midnight
and and you can find the information on
the website at thecomson.net the
helpline and web chat have answered 885
000 um calls and chats and directly
prevented 282 suicides so
um it's a lot that's a lot of
conversations
it's 14 500 hours of talking
um so people need us and we would we
want
we are there we want people to call us
i've got a question now yeah which i
want to direct
all of the guys as well um so at what
stage
in your life did you start taking your
mental health seriously and
was there sort of like a motivation
behind it that made you
want to start taking it seriously i
think i've probably started thinking
about my mental health a lot more
uh in the last probably five years and
that was the point in which i realized
that you
you have to proactively manage you and
and like this is going to sound like a
terrible analogy
but i i genuinely think about it like a
power bar or a health bar in a game
right
if you if your kind of mental health
gets too you kind of
too low then that's where you start to
get to a place where it's a problem
right you have to proactively you'll
build that health back up
you have to build that power back up
right like help you to relax
help you to chill out help you to build
back up build energy back up
and and i think for years i kind of had
that
sense of no i'm i'm fine i'm cool i'm
good with this like
you know people would say to me you're
working too hard like don't
like you're doing emails all the time
and and working all the time and people
would say to me you know you need to
chill out and i'd be like
listen i don't need to chill out i'm
fine i'm fine and i think then as soon
as you realize
actually this isn't something that's
going to manage itself you need to
proactively
get the balance and when you realize
that power bar is getting a bit low now
i need to i need to do something to
build it back up then you can maintain
that balance and i think for me it's
recognizing that it's
it is a balance right that's what i mean
about the journey it's ups and downs
it's you're never gonna flick a switch
and go oh i'm cool now
what about you ben sorry anything you'd
like to write on that one being a
minority within a minority i only
realized that it was a problem
uh in my mid-twenties i'd say when i've
realized that you know
i'm part of the lgbtq community i'm
still black within that
and um it was very very very difficult
and it was a hard hitter you know when
you start to get to know people
in this big city because you realize a
lot of the friends with you your friends
they're friends with
for one reason about that but
um when it when it comes to uh like for
me personally with mental health it was
i have to really take myself away from
that and through taking myself away from
certain communities i i
started to gain uh a lot more black
friends and i would say i
sort of found myself through them and
it's it's
very strange to say out loud but through
these
newly acquired friends these that happen
to have something in common with me i've
realized that i'm not alone they're
experiencing the same problems as me
i've
got people that i can talk to openly and
ask honestly about my struggles now
obviously the identity crisis i had when
i was younger because i was
raised in a white community you know
and the fact that i was going back to
video games i would use games to escape
the fact that i was
i was somebody else completely then you
know it's been it's been incredibly
difficult
and you know these conversations i'm
having now are
open honest you know something that i
needed a long long time ago and
if i could go back 10 years just to have
a conversation with myself it would be
you're going to be all right just be
patient and take your time there's no
rush so i've got a question for kieran
and it's has there ever been a stage
where
your content creation has suffered due
to that mental health and if there is is
there any advice that you've got
somewhat for people out there
who might yeah just to help them out
yeah definitely uh actually last year
was a
an extremely difficult year for me
because of mental health similarly to
dom actually i um discovered that i had
ocd tendencies which has given me a lot
of intrusive thoughts that made
uh streaming and creating content
extremely difficult
rather than streaming consistently like
i was before for example
um i may go like one stream a week or
two stream a week because i was finding
it difficult to kind of
get out there and and feel comfortable
doing it without my own thoughts
attacking me and then
i kind of just feel like i'd have to
sort of nap my days away or try and
distract myself from what was going and
you know try and escape from it in a way
it was actually trying meditation and
then of course
i went to therapy as well that helped a
lot and
it kind of helped me to understand what
was going through my mind and what i was
feeling and let it pass
rather than try and force it away or
fight against it if that makes sense
yeah and then with time that kind of
helped me feel more comfortable
in order to um kind of you know slowly
move forward and get back to myself and
get back into my content so i'll
definitely say
um even if you don't fully understand
what's happening if you're not feeling
right
definitely speak to someone and don't be
too hard on yourself as well
i also think it's extremely important i
i find
now when i'm not necessarily having a
good day or you know
i'm emotionally spent or uh mentally
taxed
i think it's important to let my
community know as well
so i tend to tweet a lot if i'm not
feeling too good and
you know i'm open about that and let
them know that i'm having a
kieran day to kind of react to myself
and you know
like feel better about things and like
people have been you know
really really cool about that and really
supportive so it's nice that
i can kind of have a community that is
beneficial to me as well as the other
way around so
as well as me kind of being there for
them it's nice to know that they're also
there for me in a way
no definitely i think as content
creators we
kind of sometimes overwork ourselves to
kind of meet the demands of
our subscribers or viewers however we
want to put it but i think it's good
advice
to any content creators but if you are
having an update it's okay to have an
off day
it's okay if you don't make that youtube
video it's okay if you don't make that
stream it's okay if you don't finish
that piece of work
if you need to take a date to yourself
to just
reset and realign your thoughts or
whatever you want to put it
that's fine it's okay to do that um and
now um
sorry i keep calling you no nio sorry
mate as an actor as an actor
what mental um challenges have you faced
in certain roles
or if you have facing mental health
challenges in certain roles
um and how have you overcome them well
acting in general
i will say has helped me to kind of
be okay with being emotionally
vulnerable
i think i think when you think about the
best actors in the world i think that
for me the best actors are when you can
see they're in tune with their own
emotions their strengths and their
weaknesses and they're using those to
kind of
kind of combine who they are with the
character that they're trying to portray
there's like there's many techniques
there's like stanislavski techniques
where people use kind of emotional
memory where they kind of draw upon
kind of moments in their past their own
personal
thoughts and feelings or scenarios
they've been through and they kind of
utilize those feelings
to kind of then empathize with the
character and then draw and then kind of
utilize that in whatever
piece they're doing whether that's
theater or video games or or films and
for me it's it's really opened up my
eyes to kind of being
okay with who i am and it sounds it
sounds a bit silly and a bit cliche but
it's
i think it's important because before
the the greatest struggles i find in
acting is actually
being that vulnerable allowing myself to
go to those places allowing myself to
kind of
acknowledge that okay we're taking on
some
real kind of dark issues here in this
particular text
um but i have to kind of also distance
myself and remember to kind of
decompress afterwards and say
this is just a role i i i'm going for a
role and i think
we need uh there's we need spaces like
that to allow actors and performers to
kind of
go to those spaces but also allow them
to say this is a safe space to be able
to kind of do that
when i think when i look up like i look
at video games now and some of them can
get quite violent and some of them can
go to some dark places
but um at the same time i'm grateful to
hear like
people like dom talking about how the
the studies and the science and the
kind of personal kind of experiences
that they went through to kind of get
senior with senua kind of up and running
and
i love i love hearing that because
that's that's what it's about it's about
being able to show those she's being
able to kind of explore
mental well-being and mental health in
interesting and
interactive ways but also be considerate
about those that are going through it
and also kind of
kind of display in a way that will make
people understand and empathize rather
than people kind of shun
and kind of shy away from it i i want to
point out uh through my own journey that
having issues with your mental health
does not mean that you're not a positive
person
or that you cannot be a force for
positivity also
yeah i think that's something that um i
struggled with a little bit as
like throughout my life just being known
as this positive person people
rarely know me as you know sad or upset
but
it's totally okay to be a positive
person be a force of positivity and also
have your own struggles and
and be open about that i think as a
positive person it's actually
important to express
uh that it's normal and that even people
who are deemed as positive may also go
through
these as well yeah is there anything
else apart from gaming you look to do
when you're mental isn't the greatest
like for example
when there's not gaming how do i look to
do comics or watch my favorite shows my
favorite anime what do you do
i love running i love going for like a
good run you have too much energy i know
man
some kind of dress bro
like a nice morning right away then just
like because
it's it's it's like it's like the
endorphins that you get
yeah also just like it gets my mind
energized it gets me kind of
like focused any thoughts that i've got
they're going through my head but also i
have to kind of
manage my breathing i got to kind of
maintain that energy i got kind of
maintained my speed and then it's
and then by the time i finish a run uh i
feel good about myself even though i
might have been thinking about some
stuff that i've been going through i
don't know for me i'm in that kitchen
the moment anything yeah just switch off
electrics all that phone down
kitchen music's on you will not see me
for hours on end and i would just
cook until you know until i forgot how
many hours have passed and i'm sat there
eating i'm in a good place just me
around yourself
i think i'm just going for a walk as
well right like i think i'm super
conscious that right particularly right
now like a lot of people's jobs are
under threat and stuff and it's like
if you've got a steady job and you've
got income like you've got access to a
whole bunch of stuff
netflix into games and to to music and
stuff and
for a lot of people they don't so like i
think like
literally just going for a walk dom with
senua's sacrifice
what was the biggest challenge you and
the team faced
especially because the game has a very
heavy theme of
mental health and psychosis which is um
which a mental health problem isn't
discussed a lot so what was the biggest
challenge for you guys
uh i think it was getting that right i
think i think
we wanted to kind of as soon as we
decided that we wanted to tell the story
of someone who experienced psychosis
like we knew we had to
we had to get that right and we wanted
to base it in in research
you know if we kind of had these
conversations around
look if we're going to do a game about a
character who experiences psychosis then
we need to kind of be super upfront
about that
right and go and deliver on that so i
think getting that getting that right
was the challenge and
you know when we started off the game we
um
we started talking to a guy called
professor paul fletcher who's a
neuroscientist at university of
cambridge and
he came to meet with us and started to
talk to us about the science
side of psychosis we then through
through paul had the chance to
to work with a recovery college which is
a uh unit in in cambridge
as well that helps people with mental
health difficulties to kind of get back
on up on their feet and give them a real
purpose in life
hearing these stories and um hearing
people's experiences and the things that
they would see the things that they
would the beliefs that they would have
the things that they would hear you can
find them in hellblade they're in that
game
like some of them like one for one
because
it was so compelling and and as we went
through like so many things we heard
like this is going to make for an
awesome game
it's particularly quite close to
hellblade releasing there'd be a lot of
people that would
talk to me and ask me about we want to
make a game about about mental health
like we want to
aim to try and educate people and
the balance we had to get right in
hellblade was like first and foremost it
was a compelling game like we wanted to
make a cool game that people wanted to
play
that happened to be about this character
story because if it had been
a game that wasn't compelling and was
just about education
we wouldn't have had the number of
people play it yeah there's no chance
right
but i think that kind of leads into my
second question for you because i think
i ran it interesting that you could have
just made cinema sacrifice
a game setting a celtic set in with her
as a main character but what was the
reason behind you wanting to go
we're going to make a game about mental
health um and go from there
what was what's the thought process
behind that because you again you could
have just made any kind of game
but you started to base it off mental
health yeah i think
i think to me who's our creative
director at the studio he'd been
kind of thinking about psychosis and
reading up on psychosis we've always
made fantasy games right really well
like games have been set in in fantasy
worlds and fantasy settings
um and and we wanted to do the same
again
and um kind of came across this idea
that we could
we could create a world a fantasy world
was not a fantasy world but it was
actually the the
the perception of the world from from
one individual's
um through one individual's eyes and
really exploring that idea
of actually all of us are experiencing
the world in our own unique
way there is no objective
version of the world so we we set out to
make an awesome game you know that's the
truth we set out to make an awesome game
we didn't
we didn't necessarily set out to make a
game that would educate that would
um have an impact on people we wanted to
make an awesome game that was around
this team and to do it justice
i know there's a whole bunch of people
that didn't read up on the game before
they played it
and probably played through it
or help people to understand a bit more
you know and i think that's the bit one
of the big things for me i think is
about education like i said earlier i i
feel
super privileged that i had the chance
to sit down and
to talk to people who have experienced
very very difficult things kind of
battle with psychosis day in day out and
i remember thinking like i wish other
people could have this experience as
well to learn about this because then
next time they see someone
coming down the road who might be
talking to themselves or acting in an
unusual way maybe they wouldn't cross
the road maybe
they they would think how difficult it
is to be that person
the game has clearly helped a lot of
people i've seen a lot of conversation
around
cigarette sacrifice when you guys
announced the sequel there's a lot of
you know what to expect next what what's
going to happen next so
you clearly made impacts with a single
game and i don't know whether you guys
are going to plan for any of this help a
city with sacrifice 3 or whatever but
you can't you can't you've got something
good in your hands okay you've got
something good in your hands yeah it's
definitely a different vibe to animal
crossing that's for sure
yeah fantasy prior to that i didn't know
i would
[Laughter]
it's a different experience you know i
think it's they can be it can be a
reflective experience right and
i think with hellblade is one that you
take at your own pace
you know it is tough at times you know
it is tough and it and it
and it is exploring subjects that are
tough and aren't difficult but
you know i'm super passionate about
games doing that movies and literature
have been
exploring really tough subjects for
a long long time um and now i think it's
the turn of games
video games are interactive and it means
it can kind of tackle these
kind of issues or have these discussions
in a more interesting and more engaging
way than film
music or yeah do you have to do it you
decide yeah
the game what remains of edith finch and
the how i felt
playing through that game i won't spoil
it for anyone who hasn't played it but
you're essentially kind of looking
through edith's family tree you're going
for a family tree
and you're finding out the stories of
her family and as you play through them
you start to realize
the extent in which what what each
family member was going through
uh throughout the game and you're doing
it in an interactive way because you're
playing as them and it's
and you kind of get an insight into
these different into these different
mindsets you start to empathize in
with the different situations what
they're going through and it's
it's video games that can do that
whereas i can sit down and watch a film
and it's fantastic but
me actually being that character and
taking on that person in that issue
being senua in in hellblade and
literally going along with those
going along with the decisions and
making those decisions that
can affect people in a more engaging way
than i think all the other mediums can
do
so i think the thing we found as well is
like it can
games can give people a like a language
in which to talk about their
difficulties i know with hellblade we
have people who didn't know how to
articulate the things that they were
experiencing
and found in hellblade they could say go
and play hellblade or have you played
hellblade
that's what i experienced and it gave
them a way of articulating and i
remember there was um
someone emailed us to tell us that they
they'd experienced
um some of the things that senua had and
they'd overheard their brother saying
that
he was ashamed of her because of her
mental health difficulties
and and it kind of caused a bit of a
rift in in the family she then played
hellblade and then
convinced him to play it and said listen
go play hellblade
because that's how i live my life and he
did and
um he apologized to her and said now i
now
now i understand you know and that was
you know that that's awesome
and it's not just i'm not just saying
this about hellblade but this is the
power that i think
games can have so in terms of like
lobbies
forums voice chats just communities in
general what impact do you think that
they have
on men's mental health and what more can
we do to improve it so there is more
of like an open discussion amongst
communities i think historically
they've been a really bad place
i think maybe my face kind of gave that
it hasn't historically been a
particularly
positive place um
and definitely not the place to call it
a safe space
we've had to get to the point where
people are actively
going out of their way to create safe
spaces which look
completely different to what the general
gaming community looks like says it all
the fact that we're stepping away from
that traditional
um kind of community the the way that
they're
run the kind of gatekeeping that would
happen within those spaces
and say hey this is for everyone and we
want everyone to feel comfortable here
um is not only positive but necessary
and conversations are happening and they
are being challenged there are still
a lot of i mean we'll call them basement
dwellers
um you know we know the sort of people
that are in that way inclined
um they they make it a
an unpleasant space where it has the
potential to be
completely opposite from that yeah i can
100 agree with that like a playing
games obviously all the time i tend to
now play with just friends
opposed to playing with strangers
because i know how toxic it can be like
even this morning just playing a little
bit that bad day like that i was like
he's going to shoot into a match
immediately doers uh quite a racist name
i was like well how did that get through
like usernames and certain words
and whatnot you know so you still is
still
very much there and i thought this was a
big mistake i was going to go back to
bed for a bit
while a lot of the big industries are
trying to fix that a lot of people that
do play these games and
for us as content creators we've managed
to build these communities
uh on the preface that they are safe
with us this is where it trickles down
into discord
and then we always play it together and
then we share our communities with other
content creators where we can trust and
know that they're going to be safe
they're in their discords so it's it's
like a it's like a bubble
just to keep everybody safe i will say
on the opposite end though
there are there are some good forums
that you know can
maintain some level of wholesomeness and
direct me less toxic
i would i would imagine you'd be hard
pressed to find any super toxic animal
crossing forums
the ceremony forums which is uh
cerebe.net it's um
so yeah the forums i remember being on
those quite a lot uh especially for like
trading battling and stuff and
i found uh in my personal use anyway
they were pretty good and it was kind of
nice to
kind of discuss um topics with
people who had similar interests or for
example if there was an anime episode
and everyone wanted to talk about it you
don't have friends to talk about it with
it was nice to kind of hop on there and
talk about fellow fans i think i think
that kind of leads me to my final
question for the panel which is
how do we as men create safe
environments for us to talk about mental
health
like we started off with is showing that
vulnerability
as a man you know as a male you've just
got to be open and honest with
absolutely everybody you come across
there's
there's i think people can see a mile
away now in this day and age people can
see a mile away when something
isn't right so rather than just being
inauthentic
say it you know yeah
i totally agree with that definitely um
being vocal about it yourself and then
uh not just being vocal about it but
trying to help give others the tools to
understand that there isn't something
right as well
because sometimes people don't
necessarily realize that they're you
know
not necessarily that engaged or um
in tune with how they may be feeling so
uh giving someone
the tools to kind of feel that or
understand that is very helpful as well
i think
i i think again kind of following up on
that you know
being being open being proactive in
terms of like leading those discussions
as well
i think we all know how hard it can be
to again we talked about that
first conversation that first admission
as hard as it can be to deal with our
own problems
it it is kind of i guess kind of village
mentality of you know okay
everybody else has got to be cool you
know it's not just okay for one person
to try and deal with things you know
other people are going through it
providing as many resources as possible
as we can
to other people and and taking away that
stigma as well i think it was touched
upon earlier
the stigma is a huge thing there's a lot
of stuff that we can do but i think a
simple takeaway for everyone who might
be watching this is
um ask people if they're doing okay
yeah think of your friends and your
family and if there's someone who's
you know doesn't seem quite right maybe
behaving a bit differently
you know sometimes it's it's really
difficult for people to reach out and
say
i'm not doing okay i'm actually just
saying you know however you would
say hey you doing okay or how are things
going i think if you've experienced
something yourself and you've kind of
got to a point where i think a lot of us
have in this conversation you've been
through a bit of a journey yourself
you know sharing those experiences
because that's a great icebreaker as
well
you can go hey do you know what i i've
experienced this yeah
and that really helps other people to
open up and go oh okay this is a
conversation in which i can talk about
these things and i'm not going to be
judged i remember during the first
lockdown i i literally just messaged a
friend on whatsapp just asking
him how how he was doing on the kids and
i remember him replying to me saying
you're the first person to have
asked me and it's been months um yeah
how how is he doing that is that is a
that can be a massive thing for some
people and i think a lot of the
charities
well i know that calm definitely does
like we've got a section on
if you're worried about someone he has
ways of talking to them
so if there are times when you're like
i'm not sure
again how to start that conversation
from either side
and that's quite natural and it can be
as simple as dom says of using
be like your normal language of like hey
mate how's it going
but if you genuinely feel fraught and
like this there are resources available
to help you
again find ways to have start those
conversations take the first steps
and because it is so important thank you
to all our panelists
for joining us for the men's mental
health forum
um we've really appreciated your
insights
really appreciated your thought process
when it comes to your mental health and
sharing advice with other people
um to anyone else watching that does
feel like
they want to get help or they know
someone who they think needs help
will definitely share information on
calm and their various resources
um maybe in the description or the chat
we'll show how it's gonna work
once this goes live but we will
definitely share information on
calm and what they're doing in terms of
mental health in terms of gaming
but again thank you to all our pandas
for joining us and until next time
i think with the headset as well i can
see why they put the disclaimer into
where your headset
because all the different voices you can
hear how the different angles are coming
from
it's like the it's the number one thing
i always say to people is like play the
game with headphones
all of the voices in the game we were
recorded with uh through something
called binaural audio
so binaural audio has been around for
quite a while but it's a
it's a way of recording sounds so that
when you listen back to on headphones it
sounds as if you're listening to it in
real life
yeah that's definitely noticeable it's
the first thing that i picked up on
we had all of our actors come into the
studio and the binaural microphones like
shaped like a head so you kind of
all of the actors spoke to the
microphone like it was a like it was a
person and we're moving around and i
think that really comes across in the
game definitely with the
the whole psychosis element that it
leads into as well
it feels right at times i see it
reversed she's got so many different
voices going through her head
yeah it's really interesting so we kind
of when we sat down with
people who had experienced uh voice
hearing um
and and listened to them speak about
their experiences
some of them spoke to us about this idea
of there being so many different
voices and having um so much character
in those voices
and then being able to place them in the
in the space around
so that's really what we tried to to
realize in the game was that feeling of
these multiple voices
telling you different things coming from
different directions
um so it didn't just feel like it was um
a voice within your head but a voice
that you could hear externally
you know and that was one of the things
was really striking we spoke to people
who experienced voice hearings
for some people it sounds like um a
voice that you'd hear like like you're
hearing my voice now so you really tried
to bring that across from the game i
think that's what makes it
one of the really interesting things
with hellblade i think was you know the
that we combined this story about
someone who's experiencing
severe mental health difficulties but
combined it with with the combat game
you know we're a
studio that's known for our combat
heritage and uh
you know i think it was it is it was
really interesting
to get that balance right and to make it
feel like this
struggle that cena was going through on
her journey both a physical
struggle fighting against these kind of
great hulking
enemies that she is fighting against
also the
mental journey uh psychological journey
that she's going through throughout the
story as well you can see that it
highlights it it's definitely relatable
for some people
she might be a strong fighter but you
don't necessarily want to know on the
inside
what we what we tried to create here was
uh within center of the story she had
been told about these
uh vikings and what they were like and
they were these monsters
yes when senua finds herself in this
in this place she is uh she's projecting
her own
preconceptions onto what what these
features are and then that's ultimately
what what she's
seeing from through her lens and there's
a player that's what you see as well
um which is really rooted in the the
concept of
how our minds work which is that we act
on
um inputs that we're getting in the
world right now and also prime knowledge
so
which which is something we learned from
professor
paul fletcher who's a neuroscientist
that we worked with on the project
from our very first meeting taught us
about how our brain works in that way
how we how we experience the world
around us is
its current inputs but it's also our pre
preconceived
knowledge or prior experiences that
make us see the world in in the way that
we do so in senegal's case
she's seeing the world based on the
current inputs that she's getting
through her eyes and
listen through um through her senses but
also from the information that she's
been given through her life that
these vikings are these huge um
monsters what what i i hope we've
achieved with the game as well is that
we've
we've explored these themes in a way
that
um removes the player from from modern
day life you know this isn't
obviously isn't a modern story but we're
exploring the same
you know themes that are as relevant
today as they would have been back then
um that helps maybe
to make conversations open conversations
easier between
people that have played this game that
could maybe come away from it and maybe
talk about it with the help of the game
yeah
it does because straight away you're not
your kind of
preconceptions of of things are removed
because it's in a
it's a historical setting but it's a
fantasy setting therefore the rules of
the world
are are there to be um explained to
you explain to you and for you to
interpret in your own way so therefore
your
your preconceptions are are lowered or
removed and you can look at it fresh
which
i think does help you to think about it
differently what was really interesting
uh
as well as kind of all of our research
that we did alongside with
neuroscientists and people who
experienced psychosis
and voice hearing and
seeing visions and having unique beliefs
we did a lot of work
with uh to research into
and and worked with um a really great
collaborator called
elizabeth ashman wrote who
taught us so much about mythology and so
all of the runes
that you see in the game um and all the
pathology there is accurate to
the mythology that there is around so if
you wanted to take it as a history
lesson in the game then you absolutely
that's
definitely how that's one of the first
things i noticed because me i'm quite
big on um
norse mythology greek mythology and so
on so it's definitely something i know
straight away this for me is a plus
because i'm going to be playing the game
now
yeah yeah people really enjoyed that it
was really uh
working with professor paul fletcher at
the university of cambridge who's a
neuroscientist and um
he's really interested in games really
excited about games because
to an extent in something like hellblade
you are experiencing the world in the
same way that
we as humans do you're kind of thrown
into a setting and you have to figure
out
yeah figure out the rules of the world
and and i think that's
um that's true for for everyone you know
like in in real life you have to figure
out the rules of the world and we all
have different interpretations of
of how the world of how the world works
and i think i think that does feed into
into uh difficulties that
that one can have around yeah no of
course definitely
i mean if it's very unique in a sense
whereas the game goes further and delves
into mental health
in which other games don't traditionally
do it definitely helps to
to help maybe try to change the mindset
so people maybe view things differently
because you can escape into a game if
you can relate with the game then maybe
you can relate those problems to
yourself as well and i think i think
with games
it is unique in that you are stepping
into the
shoes of someone else yeah i mean i've
done it many times myself
if i've if i'm feeling down i've
switched my games console and
do it all the time if i'm going for a
rough period i always have a specific
game that
i sort of fall back on like for me i
mentioned it before and you spoke on the
panel for me skyrim
that was a massive game for me when i
was growing up it's just sort of
you can just forget about everything
else there's been loads even if it's a
different type of gaming so
if i message one of my friends and i say
do you want to play a game of fever
there's there's so many different types
of relaxation
and zoning art and just sort of escaping
into the
whole gaming yeah and i think i think
like something that i'm seeing as well
and experiencing myself now
particularly with um the pandemic and in
lockdown is actually
because you can't get out and go to
different places
yeah you can't go on holiday and like i
love the mountains and
um you know i haven't been able to get
to anywhere where there's mountains for
a long time
you can experience those places and to
an extent in games
yeah and you can go and explore all
those places and i think there's an
added
kind of there's added value and added
pleasure now with some games
like because you can go into these
worlds and you can just just being there
you know not even engaging in the game
available like just being in a different
environment i think games can
particularly right now can offer you
that um they can take you to a different
place for sure
yeah is there anything that you've been
playing at the minute i just picked up
assassin's creed
okay yeah um uh
but uh yeah i kind of i kind of like um
yeah playing fifa you know like i think
fifa is kind of
my very much my go-to in terms of kind
of relaxation
you know i tend to also tend to the
shooters
if i'm if i've had like a bad day at
work from a [ __ ] i start
i'll get annoyed after work i'll come in
i'll sit down i'll put on maybe like
apex or warzone
that usually gets moving it usually
lists my spirits at times
yeah yeah i i think it's like um
something like fifa or pro evo like i
think
it's kind of time-bound to an extent
right you can go and have a you can
go and play it for 15 minutes and it
kind of it focuses you in that world and
it's a good breather from everything
else that's going on
i can't like i can't play online though
because i'm i'm not that great
right i'll get trounced online right so
but like for me that's a completely
different experience
yeah i'll just play i'll just play a
regular
like game against the computer right and
and set the difficulty level that's
right for me but if i
play online i find that quite stressful
because
yeah ultra competitive so it kind of has
the opposite effect for me so
like for me it has to be controlled time
control
difficulty controlled so i know that i'm
going to get some some joy out
yeah for sure but like with with
hellblade like i think
it's deliberately quite slow-paced yeah
that's i like that about a game for me
this is quite good because i don't like
to play open world games more so than
anything else for me i like to take in
the setting what's going on around you
especially if it's
when if i want to put a couple of hours
into something to spend like a
significant amount of time playing
something
yeah and it's quite interesting like
looking at something like the
traversal speed you know about a lot
like should center work
sprint um you know you can see you can
tell it's different it's definitely
designed for it
very slowly
yeah and it's yeah it's in jam we
experimented with that a lot and
actually i think like the traversal
speed makes the experience very
different like
at the times we had a like sprinting a
lot faster
but yeah it it makes it um yeah it
makes the experience really quite
different because at the pace at which
center
moves throughout the world yeah it's a
lot more considered
yeah it's like a her body language
mirrors sort of how she's
how she's feeling you can tell us
definitely yeah
yeah yeah that's could you notice that
like that it's everything we really did
in the game was
in service of her journey
she goes through so there was a huge
amount of effort went into
a lot of the monsters like say kind of
the animation in the body language and
those types of things to kind of
express how she's feeling it's one of
the benefits of having a third part
a third person game right is that you do
things even from
seeing a character back in their head
and seeing their back you can still
think do things that convey the emotion
so as you think now like with the sort
of what you touched on what you started
with
helpless you think that would lead to
sort of other games or
just being made in the same vein type of
thing do you think other people will
maybe
focus on it a little bit more and see it
as something that
can be portrayed in the game quite well
yeah i think so it's like we released
hellblade originally in um in 2017
and um i think at the time uh and it's
only three years ago but i think
it was kind of the start of a real wave
of discussion around mental health
yeah i think for us we we yeah we
released the game when there was a lot
he talked around across across
entertainment and across media
and i think since then not that we were
the first
by by any measure to to uh
kind of talk about the theme of mental
health in the game
but i think hellblade was prominent
certainly prominent and i think
i think very progressive in that sense
yeah and i think there's i think there's
now
um more games that have a mental health
theme that is central to the to the um
to the experience but i think you're
also seeing games
that are considering the mental health
of their characters within the games as
well and how they should deal with that
so even if mental health isn't
a potential theme of the game i think
it's a consideration
you know that it's being taken into
account but it's you know it's the start
mental health is one
is one subject and i think it's
obviously incredibly important
to objecting i think and like hopefully
like people find that in a game like
hellblade
it can provide for a um
a very compelling experience as well
films and and
books have been dealing with these types
of topics for
many many many years yeah there's no
subject that yeah games
games should should shy away from um so
i think it's a really exciting time and
i think
there's been just an explosion of
creativity in games i think particularly
at the indie level where
where teams and studios can just take
creative risks and tell the story that
they want to tell
and you're now starting to see that i
think
creep into into more of the
aaa space as well um i think
i think platforms like like game pass um
yeah allow for um studios like us at
ninja theory
to to delve even deeper into our
um our creative and take even more
creative risks
um yeah i think for us and for other
people um
yeah they'll be able to tackle more and
more subjects like this yeah hopefully
because
playing with senua playing this it's
been refreshing i mean i've not got that
far yet but i mean
even when i played last night for a
little bit like straight away
when i'm playing i was like yeah this is
a game that i'm gonna want to play after
i'll play the game
see the story for myself because it's
just for me it's refreshing i've not
played a game before
that even begins to sort of tackle these
issues i speak about it
and like you said respondent at the
moment is yeah it's a very good thing
when we first released it um because we
kind of we deliberately didn't tell
people too much about the game
before it before we released it there
tends to be with games like
you'll see a huge amount of content kind
of around the story and around the
setting and everything before the game
was released and we deliberately didn't
do that with hellblade because we
we wanted to keep an experience that
people could interpret for themselves
um and it was fascinating when it was
launched to just sit there and watch
people streaming it uh online yeah
see them going into it with kind of very
little in terms of expectations
like as to what the experience is going
to be like and then gradually watch them
play through the experience
and see um streamers
connect with it you know and and to see
kind of a difference in in tone as
people went through the story and see
people really connect with it and
you know which is absolutely fantastic
it's great that i think so many people
could find that they could relate to
some of senua's experiences or know
people
who who have experienced similar things
when we were speaking about it before
but the combat was really good
i thought that maybe because of there
may not be as much of a focus on the
combat system
yeah i mean senor is at the end of the
day a warrior she is a
she is she is a trained warrior um
i think one of the kind of overarching
uh elements that we were trying to
um make the player feel in combat is
that it feels like an ongoing struggle
yeah she's the underdog and that she's
she's
uh fighting against the tide um
so that by the time you get to the end
of senua's journey instead of a
sacrifice
you feel like you've been through it you
feel like you've had to battle
every step to get to um to get to the
end of
of the experience and i think that comes
across and i think
a lot of that comes across in the in the
nuance of the combat you know
like you say kind of the uh some of the
facial animation we have in there
um well while she's fighting it's it's
not easy
it's not easy and we wanted that to come
across to
to everyone that played it and it's in
our heritage right that's what a ninja
yeah i know yeah of course
i guess we're known for so um it's it's
it was always going to be a big big
focus for us to get that right
how long did it take you to like
create senior like for this game sort of
thing
in terms of her fighting style um the
voices
so i know not hers but sort of the
voices that she hears in the head how
did you come up with each of the
different voices
yeah well so with the voices it was the
first stage
really was to sit down and start with
the research
and understand the when it came to voice
hearing to understand
uh science behind the way that we well
interpret the world like i've said and
hearing is is part of that
and crucially to sit down and speak with
people who have experienced
voice hearing and hear lots of different
stories from people
about how they experienced that and you
know one of the things that really
struck me was
there is no blueprint for how people
experience mental health difficulties i
think everyone's experiences
are unique so it was really important
that we weren't
uh i think in in center as a character
trying to portray any kind of you know
this
is this is how people experience it it's
more
this is an example of how it how it
could um
manifest for people so with the voices
it was really important to sit down
to listen understand um what it's like
for people
and yeah i i remember those
conversations and i remember
hearing people talking about how
although they couldn't see
uh the people that were speaking to them
they were very much people
yeah they were very much people in their
in their life
that they had relationships people that
they share their lives with
that other people can't necessarily see
see or hear
yeah so kind of with that in mind it was
how do we give
these the voices that sent away appears
character
and life and a vibrancy that makes them
feel very much real um as they are to
senora
but without her actually actually seeing
them
and it was through experimentation we
came across this technology of binaural
audio and it sounded like a perfect fit
for us to be able to
realize the voices in a way so that you
can hear them all around you
and it's through experimentation it was
through working with actors and
not limiting ourselves to an audio food
yeah
we actually uh recorded all the voices
on the same stage that we recorded with
motion capture for the game there was a
nice big space and they could move
around
and use the physicality um you use their
physicality in the space to bring real
life to the to the voices um and i think
there's
there's also for us like uh as a as a
small team on the project
um we we we had a team of
uh it was on average about 20 people
across the three years
it took us to make the game it's a very
very small team
we couldn't realize all of the
characters in a way that you could
visualize them so we had to
we had to make uh we had to bring our
characters
to life through the audio um and our
voice actors
uh did an incredible an incredible job
of that we had so much so much fun doing
it and i think
they brought so much life to it and i
think i liked it very rewarding for you
then
to say that you put this much time
effort research into getting the
into getting the voice acting done right
or the voice and done right
and then for you to say that people have
come back to you about their experiences
and in the real world
must give you a rule yeah it must be
very rewarding yeah
it is you're right i think one of the
really really nice things is
that the in particular the voice hearing
representation in the game has been
used beyond the games actually being
used by
in academia lecturers different
lecturers are now using
the voices in in
hellblade as an example of what it can
be like to hear voices
in real life so it's kind of transcended
beyond the game experience and
and people have said to me that they
within academia and within
groups and organizations that are doing
work with voice hearing that they
feel that the voice hearing
representation in hellblade is
is the best there that there is which is
incredible because
um you know we set out to create
something that was compelling and was
truthful to the types of experiences
so for us to create something in our
game that can then
go on and be used to help other people
outside of the game experience to
understand what it's like
for people to hear voices is incredible
yeah no that really is that's amazing i
think that's the whole that's the whole
reason
why this marvel discussed in this and
for anyone out there i'd say
definitely play hellblade um experience
send you a journey because i think if
there is anyone out there who struggles
at times then
it's definitely a game that can help
them we also have a support website as
well so if you play hellblade
some of the themes in there leave you
with with questions
leave you with the feeling that you want
to reach out to people to to talk
further
then you can go to hellbladehelp.info
there's a site there and we have
links to organizations um across the
world whichever
country you're in that you can reach out
to
and talk to as well thank you once again
to all of our panelists for joining us
and to you the audience for tuning in
we really hope you leave this event with
a better understanding of your own
mental health of men's mental health of
the mental health of the men around you
and how all those things can affect you
the individual and the wider world
around you
now if you believe you or anyone you do
know needs help with their mental health
you can contact calm whose details
you'll find in description below they
have dedicated teams and services in
place to help men with their mental
health we'll also leave links in the
description below
in order to help you with your mental
health as well once again a big thank
you to gamespot for teaming up with us
for this event this has been the game
sport and the net council's men's mental
health forum thank you so much for
tuning
in
you